Din bakgrund är ju inte heller inom smicken.
Det måste ha varit ganska svårt att bara kär kan ni börja skicka till Sverige.
Jag ska dra upp en liten e-handel där borta.
Tog de det på allvar liksom?
Nej, det är väl en kär...
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Victor från Van Bruen hit till podden.
Tjena Victor.
Tjena.
Kan inte du fundera på vad vi ska börja med?
Vi kanske ska börja med, kan du inte berätta lite om ditt företag här?
Jo, men bolaget Van Bruen, jag startade för drygt 11 år sedan, 2013.
Framförallt var vi primärt en e-handel.
Vi sålde alltså bara på nätet.
Vi kallar oss även Van bruen.com initialt, precis som Amazon gjorde med amazon.com.
Sedan har vi med tiden blivit mer av det man ska använda, Buzzwords, om ni tjänar.
Vi säljer idag ungefär 50% fysiskt i våra butiker, så 50% av försäljningen sker online och 50% av försäljningen sker via våra showrooms.
Vad är det då vi gör?
Vi säljer smycken till livets stora tillfällen.
Bezel, förlåningsringar var grundfokuset från början.
Idag är det mycket andra smycken också.
Det måste ändå varit en ganska svår business att dra igång för 2013.
Smycken är inte det första man köper online.
Det var inte det som drog igång hela e-handelsvärlden.
Det måste ha varit kanske svårt att skaffa det förtroendet från start.
Verkligen, men jag har alltid gillat det som är svårt.
För ger du an något som är svårt och det är mycket hinder för att etablera dig, så betyder det att när du väl har etablerat dig så blir konkurrensen lägre.
Och som svar på din fråga gällande att det var svårt att vinna förtroende, absolut det är det.
Och väldigt mycket handlar ju om att göra saker som bygger förtroende och då kan man ju dra en parallell till alla relationer.
Du gör det du ska, du återkommer, du svarar i tid, du svarar fort.
Det var mycket det jag hade fokus på i början.
Alltså egentligen, det är en att skära kundservice, då bygga en bra relation.
När telefonen ringde svarade du direkt och ger en väldigt bra återkoppling hela tiden.
Kan vi inte hamna där lite direkt?
Vi kan gå in på alla svårigheter kring smyckesförkällning och hur ni startade och allt sånt där sen.
Men just det här med förtroende, det måste ändå ha varit något du har tänkt ganska mycket på.
Nu nämner du till exempel en god kundrelation och den här diskussionen.
Men framförallt i början där för många år sen, då måste det också varit en stor grej.
Hur vet jag att den är äkta?
Hur vet jag att detta är någonting på riktigt?
Ska jag ligga ut det med så mycket pengar?
Hur har du tänkt kring hela den problematiken?
Jag har inte tänkt så mycket på det om jag ska vara helt ärlig.
Vi har inte haft så mycket utmaningar kring det.
Folk har alltid litat på att det här är även 2013.
Jag tror faktiskt att det aldrig funnits.
Det är klart att jag kanske aldrig stötte på den kunden som misstrodde oss som varumärke, utan jag fokuserar på de som vågar.
Jag är ju själv en väldigt early adopter och litar väldigt mycket.
Jag köper själv grejer från alla möjliga konstiga ställen om jag verkligen vill ha produkten.
I början vände vi oss ju till de kunderna som gillade och handlade mycket på nätet och var den allra första kunden som var en 69-årig man som bodde i Norrland och antagligen var pensionär och inte hade så många alternativ.
Det var ju våra kunder från början.
Så han var inte early adopter, han var snarare det finns inga alternativ som ni köper.
Kunde du se det i början att det var mycket udda människor från platser som inte har en smyckeshandel nära?
Nej det tror jag inte men första kunden var ju verkligen det och man tänkte att alla första kunder skulle vara någon som det gäller mig som kanske är lite mellan kanske 30-45 år gammal som idag är våran största kundgrupp som gillar ny teknik och handlar på nätet, inte Per Arne från Norrland som är laförstående.
Jag tycker det är ganska spännande du sa att 50% är showroomen och 50% är e-handel.
Med tanke på att ni kommer från en e-handelsbakgrund så är det ganska intressant att så stor andel av försäljningen faktiskt går via showroom.
När drog ni igång showroomen och hur ser du på att så stor del av businessen går där?
Hur påverkar det expansionsplaner?
Man kan väl säga att vid den tidpunkten då vi började experimentera med detta, jag tror det var någon gång runt 2017-2018 så körde vi vår första pop-up-event och då hade vi med oss, vi har ju att trappa, vi skickade hem till kunderna, då tog vi med oss dem och hyrde ett konferensrum i Stockholm på Nobis och så testade vi det där och det var absolut inte min idé, det var en anställd som hette Jacqueline som jobbade längre hos oss i bolaget som pushade mig stenart till att göra detta för att hennes respektive sålde kläder via trunk shows som det kallas att man reser runt och så mäter och sådant, det här borde vi göra och jag tänkte nej men Jacqueline vi är en e-handel, vi ska inte träffa kunder på det sättet.
Men så tjatade hon och så sa hon att när jag kan likväl åka med min kille upp till Stockholm så kan väl vi bara bokströmmas och så åker jag ändå i hans bil och så sa jag va okej vi kör.
Och så gjorde vi det och så blev det ju en subsucces direkt och sen har vi byggt på det så vi körde i början pop-up, sen hyrde vi in oss på ett kontorshotell.
Och nu har vi ju tre stycken showrooms i Stockholm, Oslo, Köpenhamn som ligger liksom i markplan på riktigt bra adresser och så med.
Alltså för kunden så tänker man att det är en butik och skillnad mellan butik och showroom det är ju att i ett showroom så beställer du varann men du kan inte få med den och så fungerar det.
Vi har ju vissa få grejer du kan få med men för att återgå till din fråga där, hur vi tänker framåt är så är det ju det vi ser liksom som bygger businessen.
Vi kommer att doppa tårna först med ganska enkel marknadsföring i de länder vi vill etablera oss i och sen så där vi får bra respons så kommer vi ganska snabbt öppna upp nya showrooms.
Så redan nu har vi två kontrakt på bordet som vi håller på att förhandla om både för i Amstram och i Paris.
Så när det här avsnittet släpps, när det väl blir så kommer väl säkert minst en av dem vara signad.
Så det är liksom vår go-to-market-strategi kommer att vara att vi börjar ganska lätt med marknadsföring i de nya marknader vi vill gå in på.
Sen öppnar vi upp ett showroom i liksom när vi får tag i en bra lokal för då märker vi att även e-handeln hänger med starkt i de nya länderna.
Här har vi marknaden i Danmark då det vi öppnade upp senast här.
Ja, jag tänker ganska skönt med just, jag vet inte om ni kallar det för smyckesbutiker, men showroom för smycken då för att de behöver inte vara så stora.
Nej.
Det är ju skönt.
Men vad är det som gör att ni inte, för du säger att ni har ett showroom och det du sa att den stora skillnaden är att man inte säljer liksom saker på plats utan man gör snarare beställningar.
Är det en del av affärsmodellen då för att ni alltid ska kunna skicka, slippa ha lager, slippa binda kapital, slippa kanske ha det säkerhetsbordraget eller är det bara för att det är så?
Nej, men jag har ju bakgrund från finans och jag pluggade på Handels i Göteborg sen började jag på bank och alla bolag går ju i konkurs för att man inte har likviditet.
Det är ju därför och det här vill jag aldrig hamna.
Och det är ganska svårt för oss att gå i konkurs liksom idag.
Nu när vi har showroomsen har vi en del bundetkapitaler, vi har avtal och sånt med anställda.
Men i grunden så är businessen en du kan väldigt lätt skruva upp och skruva ner.
Växer vi så får vi betalt innan vi ska betala till våra leverantörer.
Så det var från början det är inte nödvändigt ont men idag så ser jag också så här om jag sitter på andra sidan, om jag skulle sälja från Brun så skulle jag ju vända mig till oss.
För jag vill ju inte som kund betala för ett stort varulag, så om vi jämför med Tiffa ni som kanske omsätter lika mycket som oss i Stockholm, så har ju de ett varulag, vad jag kan se på alla bolag, på typ 100 miljoner.
Men vi har ett varulag där i Stockholm kanske på 200 tusen, och det är ju bara attrapper och kanske lite pärlorhängen och sånt.
Det finns ju jättemycket positiva grejer.
Också en miljögrej, att du inte producerar uppvare som ingen eventuellt kommer vilja ha, för så är det ju faktiskt att även inom smyckesbranscherna, många smycken antingen, då produceras de i fel storlek och så får man ändå skrota dem sen.
Och känner du aldrig att du lämnar pengar på bordet?
Jo.
Men det får man ta liksom?
Det är helt okej.
Alltså vi har ju medvetet valt att lägga oss ett prissegment också, så att vi exkluderar ju de kunderna som vill lägga upp till kanske 10 000 kronor för tre ringar, som man brukar säga att det liksom är i ett, om du har först en förlåning och sedan en vigsel då är det ofta tre ringar.
Och där har vi säkert alltså ingen exakt siffra på det men 30-40% av Sveriges befolkning kan nog inte handla hos oss och det är helt okej liksom.
Alltså precis som ett bilvarumärke inte vill vända sig, man kan liksom inte göra alla nöjda och det tycker jag är helt fine och det är även en livsåskåring jag har lite liksom.
Ja men jag köper det, absolut.
För ni har avancerat ganska mycket internationellt redan och ni har ju en ganska fin tillväxt eller den är ju väldigt linjär och härlig och vinstdrivande.
Har ni haft några marknader där du har märkt att här skete sig?
Har ni behövt backa från några marknader?
Mm, Tyskland.
Kanske inte så förvånande svar om man ser till alltså allt från H&M till Gina Tricot till många andra moderna brands vet jag har också väldigt svårt med Tyskland.
Så vi gjorde som vi översatte sajten till tyska anställda, en tysk person som vi satte här i Borås, det är du och jag sitter idag, men vi fick tyvärr avsluta den anställningen för att vi inte fick någon traction liksom i Tyskland och vi fick inte den framfarten vi hade hoppats på.
Vi har kvar sajten på tyska och underhåller den men vi vet riktigt inte vad vi ska göra med den men det kan man väl säga att det blev ett misslyckande på flera sätt.
Ja men har du någon analys varför Tyskland skett sig?
Jag tror att mycket som gör att det går bra för oss när vi expanderar internationellt är att de flesta kunderna är inte så olika som man tror i västvärlden så har vi, vi svenskar gillar iPhone precis som att man gillar iPhone i Spanien eller USA eller var du nu än är.
Och samma sak tänker jag med våra ringar då men tyskarna, där har vi lite för vi har, har och kanske framförallt hade, vi har väldigt stiliga design på våra ringar.
De är väldigt skandinaviska.
I början var ju allvarlig produktion i Storbritannien så de är ju sprungna ur den.
Det är liksom design-uttrycket går du in i en så mycket specifikt i Tyskland vilket jag också gjorde innan vi gjorde det alltså.
Var det så att väldigt mycket smycken ser ut att de är, jag tror inte jag ska beskriva det men, romantiska, så väldigt mycket detaljer, krusiduller och så.
Inte så stilig egentligen och där tror jag det blev en krock sedan.
Finns det många konkurrenter i Tyskland, finns säkert massa andra anledningar som gjorde att vi inte fick det tempot vi riktigt ville.
Men finns det någonting som hindrar er från att bara gå in i fler länder snabbare med tanke på att som du säger ni får ändå betalt innan ni levererar, det är en ganska liten produkt att skicka.
Varför är ni inte i alla länder?
Det handlar väl om tiden skulle jag säga.
Vi hade kunnat öppna upp många fler år, det är det vi ska göra.
Ambitionen är att öppna i tre nya länder.
Det är en jättestor apparat jämfört med många andra e-handlare.
Så är vi kanske inte en e-handel längre i grunden.
Men att öppna upp tre nya bolag blir det ju.
För vi öppnar ett bolag i varje land och rekryterar personal.
Sätter upp rutiner för bokföring, betalning.
Det är en ganska stökig process tycker jag alltid.
Det är nya lagkrav du ska sätta in i.
Hur det är att vara arbetsgivare i alla länder så du har någorlunda koll även så att jag har det.
Så det är väl det som hindrar.
Men sen skulle jag inte säga det som ett hinder.
Om man bara ska ta en ögonblicksbild så är jag väldigt, väldigt nöjd där bolaget är idag på ett sätt.
Sen har jag en outtröttlig apetit på att vilja ha med.
På det sättet är jag inte nöjd men jag är nöjd var vi oss har kommit.
Men det är väldigt mycket och extremt mycket jag är missnöjd med som jag vet vi kan göra bättre också.
Det finns mycket förbättringspotential.
Jag vill gärna komma tillbaka till det men måste ni alltid starta bolag i varje land ni går in i?
Är det någonting som är med smycken att göra eller?
Nej men det är väl att det underlättar ju väldigt mycket när du har anställda och liksom allt med underleverantörer och sådant.
Alltså det kan bara vara att i Danmark där vi har bolagen men om de ska gå och köpa kaffe då liksom så vill inte Meny som det lokala ICA-tetet där eller vad man ska försätta.
De vill inte sätta en faktura mot ett svenskt bolaglist.
Det skapar också mycket förtroende.
Jag tänker bara lite kort så att folk är med på Van Brun, hur säger du?
Van Brun.
Van Brun, så klart lite hålländskt.
Jag förstår.
Ni omsatte 130 ish lite mer förra året.
I år hamnar ni någonstans runt 180.
Det ser ut som vi taktar i försäljning.
Sen är det allfrågan hur mycket vi hinner faktura ut med.
Men någonstans där i krokarna, så säg 170 till 180.
Hur ser logistiken ut kring den apparaten?
Vad är medelvärdet på en order?
Jag bara tänker på hur mycket logistik det handlar om, hur många ordrar det blir per dag.
Vad är medelvärdet?
Alltså vi kanske säljer i genomsnitt över ett år mellan 700 till 1000 ringar i månader just nu.
En väldigt behaglig mängd produkter.
Ja, och snittårdvärdet är ju kanske då, jag tror det är i dag när vi kollar tillbaka på oktober precis, så tror jag det var runt 23 000.
Lite högre i Danmark är det, så det är en ganska liten produkt, lätt att hantera.
Och som du frågade lite om flödnader, ambitionen är ju att vi inte ska röra produkterna så mycket själva, utan jag ser allt det som, Jeff Bezos, men vi ska bara fokusera på som makes our beer taste better.
Att vi touchar produkten här, det är ett misslyckande från min sida hur vi har byggt upp logistikflödet.
Det optimala är att antingen att vi bygger en egen produktion, alternativt att där vi tillverkar oss guldspen att de packar den och skickar en direkt till kund.
Så det är dit vi ska gå, då får kunder ringen en dag tidigare och det blir mycket mer lin, bättre miljön, bättre för alla inblandare.
Men du pratade lite om det innan här, vi pratade om att när, för vi var och kollade er att packrum och er lager, och från någon som sitter på 4 500 kvadrat med lager och binder stora mängder kapital i det, och det tar liksom plats och är krångligt, så är jag ju väldigt imponerad eller fascinerad av ditt lager som är liksom ett rum.
Det är liksom väldigt behagligt.
Vad, då sa du att svenska leverantörer kunde ofta skicka direkt ut till kund, men det var lite problem med till exempel engelska eller italienska.
Ja, precis.
Det är väl lite så ibland måste vi ju toucha produkterna själva så, men det är ju väldigt liten omfattningar.
Men vad är det som gör att de inte kan skicka direkt?
Vad är det som stoppar en producent?
Det är väl också hela, att du får ingen stordistfördel i det.
Alltså vi är ju vissa leverantörer som, till exempel i Italien, där tillverkar vi de mest avancerade smyckorna vi har.
Vi har en ring som heter Cannes till exempel.
Vi kanske säljer en sån per år liksom.
Och hos vissa leverantörer kanske vi bara har 20 beställningar per år då.
Att sätta ihop en hel apparat hos dem, det blir liksom inte lönsamt helt enkelt.
Okej, jag tänkte någonstans att ni hade typ, två tre leverantörer ni jobbade med och det var de.
Men ni har liksom olika för olika sorter, eller vad man ska säga.
Jag kan inte lingo till den här.
Jo, man kan väl säga som att det allra mesta vårt bread and butter, det har vi hos våra stora leverantörer.
Där har vi majoriteten i...
I någon kort har vi i alla fall majoriteten i Sverige.
Annars har vi ju, det är ju vissa grejer som är ganska...
Där du behöver ändå en specialistkunskap för att till exempel fatta.
Fatta är när du infattar och sätter fast diamanten i ett smycke.
Då är det vissa modeller, den här kupar på det sättet, då finns det bara en liten firma i Italien som är sjukt duktiga på det.
Så säger de andra, nej men det här vill inte vi röra.
Och sen är det nästa grej, så det är väldigt många av...
Så man får liksom plocka in de bästa...
Handverkarna helt enkelt, eller craftsmen på de olika delarna.
Så det helst hade man velat ha allting hos en leverantör, att vi gjorde själva, men alla är bra på olika saker.
Jag tänker, var det svårt för dig när du drog ändå igång det för...
Vad sa vi, 13 år sen?
Nej, 2013.
Och du är ju inte en gammal man, utan du är ju en relativt ung människa, och du ser ju dessutom relativt ung ut.
Så jag tänker att för 11 år sen när du gick och besökte de här producenterna, och din bakgrund är ju inte heller inom smycken, det måste ha varit ganska svårt att bara, tja, kan ni börja skicka till Sverige, jag ska dra upp en liten e-handel där borta.
Tog de det på allvar liksom?
Nej, det är väl det enkla svaret.
När jag var där så var det ingen som ville prata med mig och egentligen så sen när jag mailade så var det jag och då fick jag öppna upp ett konto hos dem vi idag har som är fortfarande en av våra största leverantörer i England.
I början betalade jag med mitt privata Mastercard varje år på shipment, vi hade ingen faktur hos dem och idag står vi för 40% av deras omsättning så det är ganska kul ändå.
Det är jäkligt kul.
Men vad var det som gjorde att de ändå tog in dig?
Det var att du betalade cash.
Jag tror att de jobbar på det sättet.
De jobbar med många mindre guldspel.
Du kan inte vara en stor kund för att bearbeta det.
Jag vet inte, eftersom det här är typ det enda jag har gjort.
Jag är bank så jag vet inte om det funkar i andra branscher men om man jobbar med kläder och så då måste du dra vissa minimivolimer.
Men för oss du kan, och nästan till alla ringlämntörer kan du ringa sig, jag vill ha en ring.
Klart du inte får ett bra deal och frakta om du blir dyr, men du kunde ändå börja så.
Så då kom ringen till mitt lokala postombud, gick jag och hämtade den, packade den på kontorshotellet och så skickade jag vidare den typ.
Ja det är roligt, jag gillar sånt.
Hur fungerar det kring säkerhet och sånt när man skickar, jag vet inte vad det kostar, för du sa att snittården är 23 000, det betyder ju ändå att de stora ordarna är betydligt större än så, jag gissar att det finns några ringar runt, nu säger vi bara ringar, ni säljer ju andra grejer också, men det blir så enkelt att diskutera ringar.
Men det måste ju finnas ordrar som ligger på 150-200 000, hur skickar man en sån produkt?
Från början trodde jag att det här skulle vara ett jättestort problem, men ser du runt i landskapet så går du i Stockholm när du är vars mesta, hur skickar alla klockbutiker sina klockor, generellt så använder man FedEx eller Postnord, REC och det är det alla gör.
Och skickar väldigt anonymt.
Jag tänkte att jag fick en iPhone till en kollega häromdagen och då skickas den från Syncron Electronics.
Det står ju liksom inte Apple på en, för att det inte man ska tro det.
Sorry om jag är outa Apple här nu om det blir massa stölder.
Det handlar ju om att verka men inte syna som vallenbärarna säger.
En ganska rolig story på det ämnet är ju, i början av 1900-talet skulle man transpirera världens dådligaste diamant från Sydafrika till England.
Och för att göra det så säkert som möjligt så gjorde man en väldigt pragmatisk riskbedömning, att bäst var att skicka den med vanligt brev bara.
Så det var det man gjorde.
Man skickade en valp-B för att det inte verkar väcka uppmärksamhet.
För man visste att 99,7% av alla brevel ändå kommer fram.
Det är ju samma med att få snor, de får ju alldeles för mycket skit i media tycker jag.
De är ju fantastiska.
Det är ju väldigt sällan de tappar bort någonting.
Så det är inget problem skulle jag inte säga.
Och vi är ju långt från de enda som skickar dyra varor.
Okej, vad spännande.
Är det mycket problem kring reklamationer eller folk som snor grejer?
Eller hur förebygger ni sånt?
Alltså reklamationer, det är klart att vi har reklamationer och alla våra produkter, vilket jag känner att det finns det inte så stor kunskap i, men alla våra produkter tillverkas ju i alla fall vi använder maskiner i stor utsträckning i alla produktionsserier.
Så är det fortfarande så att alla produkter vi har, har en, man tillverkar några moment helt förhand, vissa produkter gör du helt förhand.
Alla produkter kanske du bara polerar förhand, men alla produkter gör du förhand och det gör ju att, det är inte så att du beställer en exakt produkt, du beställer en produktbeskrivning ungefär som du går till din favoritrestaurang och du beställer en köttbit, så varje gång i alla fall du beställer en medium rare varje gång och du hade stått på det en termometer så kommer det inte varje gång vara 53,7 grader eller vad du vill ha i den andra gången, kanske 54,5 och man måste ju se att det är lite skärmen bakom.
Så det är klart vi har en del kunder som reklamerar både som nya ordare och även äldre ordare att ringen går sönder och sånt och där känner jag också det samma sak.
Att man kanske inte förstår att ringen är skörd, du kanske tar den då, men till gymmet, jag tog min ring till gymmet och skulle köra rodd och drog och så.
Nu blir den väldigt reppig här.
Det är inte guld är guld, det har sina egenskaper.
Det är inte kvaliteten det är fel på, utan väljer man en ring i guld, det är som att du kör in en bil i en vägg, den går sönder, det är inte dålig kvalitet på bil.
Så ja, vi har reklamationer men väldigt lite och de beror på att kunden kanske inte har förståelse för vad det är för vara man köper.
Det här har väl vi och hela branschen ett jobb att göra tror jag.
Hur funkar smycken där?
För jag tänker om ni tar tillbaka smycken, för ni specialbeställer får man väl säga då ändå alla smycken.
Är det som med en bil då, att så fort du har sålt den så har den förlorat typ 25% i värde, eller kan ni ta tillbaka den och ändå göra om produkten eller är den förlorad?
Alltså är den helt ny ring exakt rätt storlek utan gravid, då är den ju bara testad och då kan vi sälja om den.
Men ofta blir det faktiskt som jag ska välja att vi tyvärr behöver smälta ner den, men det är ju det som är det fina att inget material går ut i spillo.
Utan det är ju energin i så fall som är den insatsvaran som behövs.
Alltså både el eller gas, beroende på vad du har för typ av tillfälle och om mann timmar då.
Men annars är det ju liksom för miljöns sätt så är det ju en väldigt bra produkt att det är ingen som slänger guld.
Aldrig skulle jag säga.
Det är klart det händer men Det är inte med vilje i alla fall.
Nä men våra produkter har ju en väldigt hög, jag vet inte om det ens finns något mått för det men om vi skulle säga så här, hur länge den cirkulerar så finns det ju kvar ofta.
Alltså om du skulle hitta en gammal guldring i din byråd hemma då går du och antingen säljer den och så blir en ny smycknasa eller så gör dom den eller så bär du den.
Alltså det är det, det är det liksom.
Så det är ju så sättet att det är en ganska unik vara att jobba med.
Så det är kul.
Är du själv en smyckes människa?
Gillar du saker som blink?
Ja, men från början var det, det var inte därför jag började med det här men det är som Steve Jobs sa att du kan bara liksom connecta the dots, looking backwards, not looking forward.
Och jag har alltid varit väldigt klockintresserad och jag var på Baselworld som är världens största klock-
och smyckesmässa.
Den är inte redan längre men den var det.
Den är nedlagd nu men den var det och dit åkte jag liksom utan någon tanke på smycken utan bara för att jag var klockintresserad så åkte jag och en av mina bästa vänner dit.
Det är klart att den inputten och inspirationen man fick därifrån har ju såklart färgat det som idag är fan brun.
Så jag hade inget intresse för det innan men jag älskar branschen och tycker att det är skitkul.
Jag älskar att gå till jobbet, det är så kul.
Och det är mycket tack vare den produkten jag jobbat med.
Jag tror jag hade jobbat med, jag vet inte, jag bara kollar i rummet om jag hade jobbat med krukor eller judapsopenser.
Det är klart att jag hade tyckt att businessen är rolig, men det är ändå väldigt roligt att verka i en bransch man känner att man tycker är kul.
Jag köper det, men samtidigt så tror jag att nu har jag inte räknat aktivt, men jag tror att du redan har droppat tre eller fyra citat eller anekdoter från businessbyggande diskussioner.
Du sa precis här med Steve Jobs, du hade någon om Amazon här tidigare och du sa någonting.
Vi sitter här inne i ett rum och bara här ligger 16 böcker, Ray Dalio som väldigt många känner till, The Sorrowlord of Not Giving A Fuck, det ligger Resan Thiel, Hållbar e-handel, Built to Last som är också en klassiker.
Det känns ju som att du ändå har ett visst intresse för att bygga bolag och inte bara produkten.
Så frågan är väl egentligen, det känns ju lite som att det också är att bygga bolag.
Absolut, men det är det.
Men det är ju som om jag är kock, så gillar jag Italien då, kanske jag heller jobbar med italiens mat, en produkt jag inte gillar framför mig liksom, eller att jag är djur i skog och får jobba med väggtag, så kanske jag gillar att jobba med kött i hans fall.
Så det tror jag, men absolut i grunden hade jag inte gjort det här, säger att fan brun, hade vi gått i konkurs.
Ibland tänker jag bara, det hade varit spännande, för det har fått början och nu har jag lärt mig en massa grejer, för jag har gjort så mycket misstag.
Vad är det du gillar med att bygga bolag?
Jag vet faktiskt inte.
Jag tror jag gillar att göra saker väldigt mycket.
Jag har alltid gillat, min pappa när han levde var en väldig entreprenör, fast det blir aldrig något stort.
Men väldigt entreprenör, tänk.
Jag berättade det många gånger innan, men det var nog möjligt att jag inte skulle starta ett bolag.
När jag var liten, han engagerade mig väldigt mycket i olika typer av entreprenöriella äventyr.
Vi byggde en go-kart ihop och hela tiden pushade fram mig och försökte.
Så jag tror att man gillar att göra saker.
Jag gillar inte så mycket att bara slappa det jag gör med, kanske någon gång då och då, men jag gillar inte att bara, jag gillar att tänka.
Jag gillar inte att konsumera så mycket.
Jag läser aldrig någon skönlitteratur till exempel, men som du märkte här inne, och det här är bara en liten del av alla böcker, men jag läser ju och konsumerar väldigt mycket information kring business.
Och ju mer man läser något, så blir det ju ofta så att det blir ännu roligare.
Det finns många spår jag hade kunnat ta här, men jag sidestäppar några stycken eftersom, när jag kom hit så satt du i ett möte med dina kollegor, och då höll ni på att göra någon viss sorts möte som inte bara är ett vanligt möte.
Och det jag menar med det är att du får jättegärna berätta vad det var för möte sen, men håller du hela tiden på att testa de här olika principerna, eller de här olika grejerna?
Är folk på kontoret lite trötta på när du kommer in och bara ja men jag har läst en ny bok, nu har jag en ny take på hur vi ska göra det här.
Så det är lite olika frågor igen.
Men testade du runt väldigt mycket och vad var det för möte du hade?
Enklast svaret är ja, jag testade runt extremt mycket och vi ändrade oss väldigt mycket.
Jag säger det, att vi är ingen, vi var inne på det lite innan, jag tror väldigt mycket på att man inte ska tilltala alla, för då blir det aldrig bra för någon, då blir det liksom halvdåligt för alla istället för vi är extremt hållfissa och väldigt bra.
Så vi är en väldigt speciell arbetsplats på det sättet, tycker jag att det ändras väldigt mycket och det är högt tempo.
Vi är ett företag baserat på forskning, inte vad jag tycker utan vad forskningen tycker.
Om man tycker att allt från remote work till hur ett möte ska byggas upp, så om det kommer en artikel från Harvard Business Review eller en bok som jag tror stenhårt på, då vänder jag 180 grader direkt liksom.
Då fimpar vi det om ännu mer än vad vi har gjort i tio år.
Så exempelvis de möten vi börjar med nu, vi har ju bantat bort möten, för jag läste någonstans nyligen faktiskt, så det håller jag verkligen med om att har du möten så är det ett tecken på att kommunikationen i ditt bolag är bristfällig.
För när du är själv och startar ett bolag så har du ju inga möten, för då har du all information själv.
Är du två stycken så sitter ni bredvid varandra och delar i princip all information, det finns väldigt lite möten.
Men i takt med att antalet individer i en organisation ökar så krävs det mer möten för att alla ska dra åt samma håll och undvika missförstånd.
Så därför har vi börjat köra möten som Amazon och även till viss del Google har.
Vi kör med pagers, alltså att man skriver det som ska sägas på mötet.
I förhand där det är en person ansvarig som jag till exempel skulle ha en idé av ett pager, då skriver jag ihop en pager som egentligen är att du skriver ihop en sidra och den kan vara en eller sex sidor.
Och när mötet börjar så sätts alla i en lässal och bara sätter sig och läser igenom allting.
Antecknar frågrunder tiden och sen när vi har läst klart så går vi igenom alla frågor och sen fattar vi beslut.
Så det mötet vi hade imorse här var vårt månadsmöte.
Så då redovisar alla avdelningar, vad som har hänt under månaden, learnings, findings, vad kan vi göra bättre framåt och vad behöver vi sprida för kunskap i organisationen.
Och sen så kör vi frågor på det och ja, och svararna är de få som inte kan vara med på mötet.
För då är vi alla i hela bolaget med på länk och så från de tre andra kontor.
De får ta del av den informationen då i efterhand.
Och det tycker jag är väldigt bra, alltså jag på semester eller inte kan vara med på ett möte så får jag andra exakt samma information eftersom att det är ingen powerpoint.
Utan vi har, precis som Amazon, förbjudit powerpoint.
Vi kör aldrig det, utan det är liksom hela meningar som Jeff Bezos säger.
Och du kan formulera det och uttrycka det, du kan ha med tabeller på det sättet du bäst vill kommunicera.
Jag blir alltid så fascinerad när, alltid när jag spelar in de här avsnitten och när jag träffar företag som det har gått bra för, ni verkar så strukturerade hela tiden.
Jag känner alltid att jag har ett skojbolag utepå, på vishan.
Det är så här, fan, vad allting är på riktigt.
Upplever du själv att ditt företag är på riktigt eller tycker du fortfarande att det känns som att, inte att du är fejkare men liksom att, du försöker fortfarande lära dig.
Jag känner exakt som du gör att vi är ett skojbolag.
Det gör jag hela tiden.
Nej men jag tror man alltid ska göra det också.
Att man inte ska ta det på för stort allvar, det är bara ett jobb men, vi saknar väldigt mycket grejer också.
Som gör att, kommer du från ett stort bolag så kommer du, få en ganska stor omställning om du börjar jobba här.
Vi har sett ofta att det varit våra sämsta rekryterare, till exempel när vi har tagit in personal från stora bolag.
För att de kanske upplever oss då som ett skojbolag.
Men, ja, jag tror liksom att man är ett skojbolag, annars kan man ju tänka att man är ett naivt bolag, och det är ju ofta de naiva bolagen tror jag, som vågar testa grejer som man ifrågasatt i gamla sanningar och sånt.
Alltså typ såhär kan du inte göra.
Men det tror jag visst vi kan göra.
Och det är bara för att du eller jag inte vet bättre.
Och det gör ju att vi hamnar på nya ställen.
Jag vet att jag har lyssnat på lite av din andra poddar som du har suttit i och sådär.
Och då nämnde du vid något tillfälle att när du drog igång i andel så tog det typ om det var två veckor eller nån sån där eller fyra dagar.
Jag kommer inte ihåg men det tog ett tag innan första åren kom.
Och den gick du typ back på.
Och jag gissar att speciellt där i början var det ganska lång tid mellan ordrarna och säkert de första åren var det på det sättet innan det verkligen rullade.
Men när, kan du komma ihåg att när du insåg att fan det här är på riktigt, det här kommer jag nog antagligen göra de närmsta tio åren.
Jag kommer inte behöva liksom lägga ner bolaget.
Alltså där är jag ändå nog idag, men det är svårt att säga när man har hamnat där, men det var inte jättelänge sedan.
Jag skulle nog säga att det är ungefär när vi flyttar hit till den här fastigheterna, men säger fyra år sen då när vi gick över 50 miljoner i omsättning ungefär, tror jag det var.
Någonstans där tror jag att det var ändå.
Man kände sig här, då hade vi ändå en solid bas.
Men jag tror då fick vi in en order varje dag, typ under ett år, annars kunde det verkligen vara.
Alltså det är än idag vissa dagar vi får in, det var inte så länge sen vi fick in 12 order en dag.
Alltså nu pratar jag inte år sen, nu pratar jag veckor sen.
Alltså det var någon dag i september när vi fick in 12 order och jag bara, ja då är jag färdiglekt med det här.
Får du också den här paniken så fort en dag går dåligt?
Alltså inte längre men det var inte längre sen.
Det är klart om det går dåligt i en vecka men, alltså det där är ju sunt, alltså nu ligger inte det i en bok när jag står hemma, men Only the paranoid survive.
Jag läste ungefär samma böcker inser jag.
Ja, men det är ju så det tror jag.
Alltså för då berodde det till exempel på att då kunde vi hitta orsaken till det och korrigera den.
Hade jag varit lugn i det läget, så hade det gått mycket länge innan vi hade sett det.
Så det är ju bra att du märker.
Det är ungefär som om det börjar lukta rök hemma.
Ibland kanske var det steket bacon, men ibland kanske huset brinner liksom och då är det bra att du är lite paranoid.
Jag har en sån cutoff när klockan är elva, för jag går alltid och käkar lunch vid elva.
Jag är ju gammal, vi är ju ofta på byggen och sånt där och bygger och då käkar man tidigt lunch, för man är ofta uppe tidigt.
Men vid elva, om inte vi har nått över en viss summa, som jag har i huvudet, så får jag alltid lätt ångest typ.
Så måste jag kolla folks mailar och se, ligger det nån ungefär på G, finns det nåt som...
Det är alltid så, jag kan inte släppa det.
Nej men det är nog bra tror jag.
Jag tror det är jättebra.
Du nämner FAM-brun, om jag ska uttrycka det korrekt.
Ni skriver om den här FAM-brun på hemsidan.
Det är ju ett väldigt bra namn, för det låter ju...
Det låter liksom, inte gammalmord, men du vet, klassiskt om jag skulle säga det så, det låter liksom professionellt.
Jag vet inte vilket ord jag ska använda, jag har inte det genuint på något sätt.
Dels var kommer namnet ifrån, men framförallt ni skriver det nästan som att det här ska vara en person på hemsidan.
Är det så ni ser på, när ni tar designspråket eller luktspråket som du pratade om tidigare när vi gick runt på lagret, är det den här personen som ni då föreställer er?
Om vi börjar med namnet så, det kommer ifrån att jag heter Halvarsson Efternamn.
Det är kanske ett namn som i alla fall i Sverige skulle jag säga, det är inte supervanligt men jag har inte följt med något adligt efternamn eller något coolt efternamn, det behöver inte vara farligt.
Vad är ett coolt efternamn?
Jag bara menar att man hade kunnat ha ett kort och slarkraftigt efternamn som är lätt och ändå ta till sig alla och som inte, min farfar till exempel, det är ett bolag som heter Halvarssons Motor som på något sätt finns kvar på någon form idag, men så söker du på Halvarsson så får du upp massa grejer på Google.
Och jag har alltid varit väldigt bra på Google, jag vill ju ha något namn som var, om du skrev in det så fick du bara upp det, så jag är tvungen att hitta på ett varumärke, och de flesta varumärkena, eller nej, nu suger jag, men många varumärkena, bland annat Gina TK som är från Brose, är också ett påhittat namn.
Och när jag hörde det då att de hade gjort det så tänkte jag, men jag gör samma grej, det har gått jätteprof för Gina TK.
Och då började jag bara spåna och så finns det ju mycket svaromärkningar som kommer från nederländerna runt där, bland annat Van Cleef en Aarples och en massa andra.
Det finns några som gör en pjama som heter Fanlac också.
Och då tänkte jag, men jag tar det.
Samtidigt så gick det en film som hette Limitless med Bradley Cooper och Robert De Niro och då hette antagonisten där som speldes av Robert De Niro, han hette Carl Van Loon och det tyckte jag var ett sjukt snyggt namn.
Men det var ju en annons, det var ju en massa människor som hette det på riktigt.
Så då spånade jag bara fram det, precis som det här reklambyrån gjorde åt Ginnatrikås, så spånade jag själv i mitt huvud för jag inte hade råd med någon reklambyrån.
Och så blev det Fanbrun, och det är ingen som heter, det är vad jag vet i verkligheten.
Och det är ju att det är väldigt lätt då när man ska regga varumärken och sådant i alla länder.
Vi äger ju det varumärket i USA och allting liksom, det var inga problem.
Så det är väl ett tips om det är någon som ska starta något varumärkel.
Heter du inget unikt, ta ett namn som är unikt, för det är bara så mycket stämningar och grejer som man inte ser med Apple, med iPhone och allt vad det är i alla länder.
Sen din andra fråga, nu har jag tappat den.
Vem mäter ni liksom i ett designspråk mot den här påhittade figuren?
Nej men vi har nog med oss...
Eller vem är den här figuren?
Ja, nej men det är väl mer för att formulera en känsla att jag tycker att väldigt många försöker se sin produkt som något annat än en commodity, men faktiskt menas att alla produkter är bara en commodity.
Om jag ska gå och dricka en öl brukar jag ta som ett exempel på en väldigt commodity bara.
Den kan jag få på Barry Borås där vi sitter på säkert 50 ställen.
Men jag väljer ju att gå till två, tre ställen, alltid, varför gör jag det?
Jo men det är ju för den här känslan och det som finns runt om.
Alltså det är allting från inredningen till personalen, till musiken som spelas, och det är ju liksom en persona kan man väl säga, eller liksom någonsats ett varumärke då, liksom som en kalsprö eller vad det nu är förr, ska servera sig.
Och på samma sätt då ville vi ha något sätt att uttrycka, liksom en, alltså en metallbit med en diamant på.
Men det är så mycket mer, vad är det som är mer?
Jo men då ville vi ha något sätt att beskriva det, och då kom vi på att bäst att tänka då att det är en person liksom, som är en sofistikerad, men som kan väldigt mycket, som är väldigt vänlig, men som samtidigt har en ganska stor lättsamhet i allting, alltså inte tar sig själv på för stort allvar.
Så vi är som en kvarterskrog där det är superbra mat, superbra stämning, men där det inte är liksom, om du tappar en gaffel att det blir helt knäpptiskt där inne, utan att det är liksom en lättsam och väldigt till mötesgående ton.
Jag fattar.
Det har ju gått bra för er, och hur gammal är du?
35.
Och du har hållit på med detta i 11 år, då var du liksom 24 när du började detta.
Och innan jobbar du lite grann på bank i några år.
Det är ju relativt enkelt för dig att skapa en ganska dryg personlighet.
Om du förstår vad jag menar, det har ju ändå gått ganska bra, men jag upplever ju fortfarande, nu känner inte jag dig, och vi har liksom inte träffats innan det här, men jag upplever att du har ett ganska stort nybörjamindset och det känns ändå som för folk som läser sådana här böcker, så du har ju ett growth mindset jämfört med ett fixed till exempel.
Du verkar ju ganska flexibel eller när jag kommer hit så är det så här, ja men kom här och kolla på lagret här och kika här och väldigt öppen sådär.
Och jag märkte även, det här är att dra det lite långt, men jag märkte att du var på väg att säga ett fabricerat namn, men du sa påhittat istället och det gör man ju ofta för att prata i ett språk så att alla hänger med i diskussionen till exempel, och det är ett väldigt fint sätt att göra dialogen på ett sätt så att alla hänger med då till exempel.
Vad är det som gör att du inte är dryg är min fråga.
Smycken känns, om jag går in och jag tänker, det här är en människa som har startat ett bolag som inom två år omsätter en kvarts miljard inom smycken och som är relativt ung, då kommer jag att tänka, helvete det här kommer vara en dryg jävel.
Det känns inte så just nu.
Nej men alltså det beror nog på, jag ska inte säga att jag är dryg, det vill jag absolut inte vara.
Är det för att du är från Borås?
Nej men jag tror det handlar om att jag läser mycket.
Alltså att jag, jag tror, alltså nu står inte det här i boken, men det är en av de böcker som har införgöt mig allra mest, det är Extreme Ownership heter den boken, och den handlar verkligen om att du äger ju allting i ditt liv som händer som är bra eller inte bra, och då tänker jag, vad kan jag göra i min sits varje dag mot alla människor jag möter.
Alltså jag vill ju att du blir en reklampelare för mig och mitt bolag och mig och mitt personliga varumärke.
Vad händer om jag behöver hjälp en dag med att bygga ett gym här eller liksom så.
Så jag försöker alltid, om jag går på ICA eller vad den är, så har jag en underbar dag nu, har det gått liksom.
Jag försöker aldrig vara dryg mot någon.
Sen kan jag säkert vara det ibland också tyvärr.
Men jag försöker det.
Det är väl att jag, alltså där är jag väl taktisk liksom helt enkelt.
Så vet inte jag om, nej men vet inte.
Men samtidigt har väl det blivit en del av min person tror jag.
Så jag ska inte säga att jag förut var dryg, men jag tror jag är mycket mindre dryg idag än då.
Sen kan jag nog vara dryg i vissa situationer.
Ja för jag vill vända på frågan sen, jag vill höra vad är dina sämsta egenskaper som ledare egentligen?
Nejmdropper har jag mycket namn men Elon Musk det tänker jag alla vet.
Men jag vet att han säger nej till väldigt mycket och det är jag också.
Alltså extremt mycket.
Det är faktiskt så att några av mina vänner kallar mig Mr Nene för att jag säger nej väldigt mycket och det handlar ju om att jag får säga nej till väldigt mycket för att kunna säga ja till det jag verkligen vill göra.
Så jag är ju väldigt rationell med min tid och det gör att jag säger nej till mycket.
Och där tror jag att jag kan uppfatta som extremt dryg.
Alltså jag har skårat sagt när någon föresöker att när jag vet att någon ska flytta, ja men då vet jag såhär, det är bättre för mig att jag åker ner och jobbar två dagar och hyr in en flyttgubbe som står där, Victor flyttgubben på mössan och så kommer jag upp och käka pizza med dem sedan.
Så där är jag väl jättedryg alltså.
Men det är det jag tror att du måste vara också.
Och jag är väldigt dryg, jag säger nej till släckkalas och liksom allting som jag känner inte adderar något värde.
Så jag kan ju nog framstå som ganska egoistisk i de fallen liksom.
Tror jag.
Ja, jag köper det.
Jag har också under många många års tid alltid gått hem klockan nio om jag är med kompisar, så de har liksom slutat tjata för att man vet att jag sitter där, jag tar mina tvåel, jag är med liksom och sen men jag stänger alltid kvällen tidigt för att ofta var det så att jag skulle hem och jobba då.
Nu är det ju barn istället men liksom man får ju prioritera.
Det är inte så konstigt.
Vad är, du har inga barn?
Jo.
Du har barn?
Ja, en dotter har jag.
Okej.
För jag vet att det som du har nämnt som en av dina framgångsfaktorer tidigare har ju varit att du jobbar extremt mycket och verkligen sitter och jobbar.
Och då pratar du även om att när jag får barn så vill jag kunna vara lite mer närvarande och sånt där.
Hur går det?
Nej men jag tycker det går väldigt bra.
Jag är ju, det tror jag är väldigt, många som är förvånade med att jag ändå är pappaledig ja men, kanske en till två dagar i veckan så.
Det var det jävligaste.
Okej, det ser man bra om också.
Det tror jag många är förvånade med men fördelen är ju att min respektive Alexandra, hon jobbar också på Fanbrun, så vi är ju liksom som en cirkus lite, alltså att åker vi till, ja men ska jag ner till Köpenhamn och besöka showroomet där och träffa dem, mina kollegor där nere, så åker ju hela familjen med liksom.
Så vi gör ju det som en grej och så sitter Alexandra och jobbar med datorn i passagerasätet medan jag kör och så ligger, och så lyssnar jag på någon ljudbok av mig, av mig företagare och så säger jag att du måste skriva upp där, du måste skriva upp där och så sitter Paloma, då våran dotter, i baksätet och sover kanske liksom.
Så vi, vi, det ska bli intressant att se vad hon är för person sedan hon blir äldre, men just nu tycker jag det fungerar väldigt bra liksom och de dagarna jag är hemma, hon sover ju, hon är ju fortfarande, hon är ju tio veckor bara så.
Jaha, det är så färskt, vad roligt, då är det inte så konstigt att jag inte visste om det.
Nej, så då, hon sover ju ganska mycket, du vet hur det är, och då får man ändå tid att jobba, liksom jag är inte den som när hon sover att jag sover, eller när hon sover att jag kanske går och grejar så mycket hemma på gott och ont, men utan då sätter jag mig med datorn så fort det går, liksom hon och jag är ju utåtgå, så lyssnar jag på en ljudbok liksom, men jag försöker inte schema lägga några möten eller sånt när jag är pappaleder, eller det gör jag inte.
Okej, vad roligt att du lyckades balansera upp det.
Ja, vi får väl se hur det fortsätter.
Men du blir ännu mer no-no mot vännerna kanske.
Ja.
Då finns det ännu mindre tid sen.
Jag tänker också på den här, du pratade ju också lite grann om att ni skulle gå in i tre länder här, till exempel närmsta, hur mycket hungr är kvar.
Är detta liksom mer ett jobb nu eller en process som du rör framåt?
Du till exempel lyckas med att ta pappaledigt, till exempel det kanske man inte hade gjort första åren för att man var så pass stressad över situationen att driva framåt.
Hur upplever du att hungen kring att bygga bolag har förändrats?
Jag skulle säga att den är ännu större nu.
Innan var jag absolut mer tidig innan.
Nu jobbar jag sällan, eller jag jobbar kanske varje helg lite grann om man ska sluta, men på semester och sånt.
Eller jag brukar säga att jag aldrig har semester men att jag helg alltid jobbar för jag tycker att det är så kul att jobba så jag känner inte på det sättet.
Men jag har hungen ännu större, för jag tycker att det är mycket roligare nu också.
Jag har inte samma eftersom jag räknar på om hela Sverige skulle gå bara att stryka.
Så har vi ändå tillräckligt med omsättning i de andra länderna för att det ska vara en bra business.
Så jag har mycket större hungrig, det är mycket roligare nu.
Jag har aldrig varit så lycklig överlag i livet tror jag som jag är nu och det är inte bara med Paloma, min dotter, utan det är ju liksom allting.
Alltså det är väldigt på en väldigt bra plats och det gör att det blir roligare att jobba.
Så jag har ju en väldig hungrig.
Jag tror i början, trodde jag, eller jag var ju väldigt motiverad av pengar initialt men sedan man vet ju det att fallforskning säger att vi är 50-60 000 i månaden någonstans.
Det är väl lite högre nu med inflation så blir du inte lyckligare och jag tror det stämmer liksom.
Har du råd att kunna gå ut och käka med dina polare och inte ha en stress över om man ska splitta notan, då för mig är det en ekonomisk frihet, allt annat är bara excesser.
Du kan bo på ett dyrare hotell eller kanske ha en dyrare bil eller whatever.
Det är inget som gör dig lyckligare, men har du möjligheten så lägger man ju de pengarna.
Jag brukar tänka att, för mig är det kan jag köpa lunch, då känner jag mig lugn i huvudet.
Så i vissa perioder när jag behöver ligga ut med mycket pengar i bolaget, för vi har ju inte den här fina likviditetsprocessen som ni har, utan i vissa inför black week till exempel, då ligger jag ju ut med mycket privata pengar, då är jag ju tom liksom.
Och då känner jag mig alltid fattig för att jag inte kan, för att jag tänker på vilken lunch jag köper.
Så det är verkligen de här små varor.
Jag tänker inte på lånet på huset, jag tänker på den här fucking lunchen.
Men det är jag likadant.
Jag kan ju bli lite redd om min sambo och köper jordgubbar, för det kostar ju 60 spänn.
Det är en lunch liksom.
Bra lunch i Borås som kostar 60 spänn.
Alla lyssnar i Stockholm.
Jag har kanske inte 60 spänn, men det är inte långt ifrån.
Men hela det är att jag är ju ändå väldigt snål med vissa grejer.
Jag har ju hört att du är rätt snål.
Eller du har sagt att du prutar väldigt mycket.
Du har någon policy kring att man måste pruta tre gånger innan man säkert hatar era leverantörer.
Nej men alltså, om man tänker på det så här istället, alltså någon annans marginal, det är ju ineffektivitet som du måste betala för.
Så brukar jag tänka.
Och det har jag ju fått från Sam Walton som startade Walmart, Your margin is my opportunity.
Och det tycker jag är så sant, att man vet att det här är för dyrt.
Det är liksom, jag kommer inte att betala för att de här inte, att de har en massa ineffektiva möten eller sitter i en flådlokal i Stockholm.
Om de vill kunna göra det och de måste lägga på massa, då tycker jag att jag har skäl att kunna få det för, alltså, och det är ju bara ett bud om de inte vill acceptera det.
De behöver inte göra det.
Det hoppas jag inte någon, eller det finns garanterat många som tycker att det känns drygt och otrevligt och så, liksom, men jag tror att det finns väldigt få framgångsfika personer som ser det på det sättet.
Om du lägger fram att jag vill betala det här och då man säger nej, då har man rätt att säga nej till det.
Är dina inköpare ännu värre än vad du är?
Både ja och nej, det finns väl vissa som är väldigt duktiga och man blir väldigt skolad i det.
När man är ny här så är det ju alltid så här, har du prutat tre gånger?
Vad säger de då?
Du måste vara hårdare liksom.
Och vi måste kolla här och jämföra här.
Och jag säger det, köper vi in någonting i Sverige som vi vet tillverkas nån annanstans så misslyckas vi.
Och då får vi vara fine med att vi gör det.
Alltså till exempel om vi köper paraplyer, det finns ingenstans i Sverige, gisser jag, där det tillverkas paraplyer.
Varför ska vi inte köpa reklambrandade paraplyer direkt från Alibaba liksom?
Och om vi går till Avicera eller vad de nu kan hitta, låtsamma jag slänger dem under bussen.
Ni vill alltid gå till källan och där får så bra pris som möjligt.
Ja alltså jag tänkte såhär, de adderar vi ju inget värde till kunderna.
Det är ju ett misslyckande från vår sida, om inte de adderar det värdet, så får de antingen ta bort det övflöde värde som de tror de adderar eller så går vi runt dem.
Kan inte vi som kund som köper smycken känna likadant?
Jo, absolut.
Det är ju vår uppgift att ha en så bra produkt.
Då är det inte bara ringen i sig, utan det är allting runt om.
Det är det jag ofta pratar om.
Jag tror att vi har ju alltid varit väldigt duktiga på värde.
Att ha en väldigt högkvalitativ produkt till ett bra pris.
Det har varit vår paragrafin när jag startade och då var det ju 30-70% lägre pris än traditionell handel.
Det var ju liksom vår, jag kommer ihåg det var så jag skrev de första Google adsen.
Men idag skulle vi aldrig säga på det sättet.
Idag är vi mycket mer premium och står för det.
Men med det sagt, det är ju liksom vår produkt, precis som nästan alla andra, är en commodity i grunden.
Det är ju liksom runt om.
Vi måste ju rättfärdiga det för kunden.
Att det är det här vi adderar.
Jag tycker bara det är lite spännande.
Där skiljer vi oss väldigt mycket åt.
Jag är väldigt tids...
Jag köpslår alltid med tid.
Så jag är alltid ganska flexibel med kostnader och liknande så länge alla andra tar hand om jobbet och det löser sig väldigt smidigt.
Däremot omger jag mig med kollegor som är betydligt mycket snålare eller vad man ska kalla det ekonomiska än vad jag är.
Så de stoppar ofta mina mail eller mina diskussioner och så tar de över.
De stör sig på att här kunde vi komma undan med 200 spänn eller här hade vi kunnat lösa det såhär.
Vilket jag tycker är fantastiskt och så vill jag ha det.
Men det är också, jag har nog fokuserat för mycket på vissa kostnader.
Det är jag helt säker på.
Alltså ett klassiskt, det är ju jätterationellt att till exempel ta in städhjälp hemma liksom för i princip alla som jobbar med kunskapsbaserade yrken liksom.
Det är ju bara så det är.
Och där har väl jag snålat liksom och inte gjort det varken privat eller på jobbet.
Det tog det ju säkert fem, sex år innan vi gjorde det eller som jag berättade för innan att jag bokförde själv liksom.
Det är ju jättefel av mig.
Men i vissa fall så tror jag att vi kanske går för långt och ibland kan det vara så här jag sitter och letar fram den billigaste datormusen till kontoret i Stockholm.
Ja, här har de en drive.
Och så sparar jag 40 kronor.
Så lägger jag 25 minuter på det och min nedlagda arbetstid, om man då ska bara formulera om den bara till min lön liksom som inte liksom alls sticker ut så.
Så är det ju åt helvete att jag sitter då och jag borde bara ta den första bästa, köpa den på Amazon för att gå snabbast där.
Ja men jag gjorde exakt så någon gång.
Jag räknade vad jag drar in i timmen.
Och så räknade jag på ja men vad kan jag göra för arbetsuppgifter då?
Ja men nästan ingenting.
Ja men då alltså säger jag allt det.
Och så gör jag bara det där jag känner tillbaka det jag borde dra in eller ge ett större värde.
Och då blir man ju nästan bizarr i vad man kan lägga pengar på.
Det är såhär, ja det är ju som du säger.
Absolut men sen tror jag att, nej alltså det är en svår balansgång det där.
Jag håller ju fortfarande på så ganska mycket liksom och vi ifrågasätter ju väldigt mycket kostnader internt också liksom.
Alla har ju möjlighet att köpa in grejer på bolaget men man blir väldigt mycket ifrågasatt för mycket feedback.
Jag tänker att du tog tidigt in en vän eller en bekant som delägare.
Nu kommer jag ihåg hans namn.
Filip.
Ja.
Kan du inte berätta lite om det beslutet?
Nej men du var inne på det här.
Första åren tog två veckor.
Det blev ju ganska påfästande mentalt och leva med den stressen.
Så jag startade ju bolaget i, rent formellt bildades ju bolaget August i 2013.
Sen sålde vi första ringen 14 april 2014 och släpptes hemsidan första april 2014.
Så det var ju inte så sen att första åren kom in en till dagen efter, utan det var ju en vecka där och sedan var det tre dagar.
Sedan var det tyst i sju dagar till.
Så det var ju väldigt, väldigt påfästande.
Så det ledde ju till att jag ungefär ett år efter att jag startade bolaget och så åt jag lunch med Fyltor och vid den tidpunkten var vi bekanta kan man väl säga.
Vi umgick inte.
Och då hade jag alltid sett upp till honom och visste att han hade gjort en del bra andra investeringar.
Han är ju bara ett år äldre än mig, men han hade ändå liksom tidigt kommit in och jag såg upp mycket till honom så.
Ja.
Vad var det du såg upp till?
Jag visste att han hade investerat i många andra bolag.
Han var en som var väldigt mycket för om sig och kring sig.
Han hade väldigt bra koll, jag tycker att jag har väldigt bra koll på finans och hur det lägger upp.
Han hade väldigt bra koll på en sådan grej att när han sommarjobbade, så sommarjobbade han på skatteverk.
Det var inte för att han tyckte att det var kul utan bara för att lära sig kring det.
Hur lägger du på ett så effektivt sätt som helt upp din skatteplanering i bolaget med 312-regler och allt sånt?
Jag kan säkert mer än 99% av Sveriges befolkning, men han kan mer än att det finns fåa som kan så mycket om det.
Då ville jag in honom så istället för att fråga honom rakt ut så bjöd honom på lunch och frågade om han visste någon som var intresserad och investerade.
Då sa han lite namn och sen skickade han till sms på karlen.
Jag är intresserad.
Man kan både se det som att jag gjorde min bästa deal i livet och min sämsta.
Han köpte in sig med Fasityanda och om man kollar vad start-ups, alltså Jättebilt, han köpte ju 40% av bolaget, för jag kommer inte ihåg exakt, men under en miljon.
Men vi hade ju varit omsatt kanske en tredjedel av det vi gör idag utan honom.
Det är för att han är min kravställer som eldar på.
Han har ju lärt mig mycket att pruta, kan man säga.
När vi var på första mötet hos våra leverantörer i England, då var väl jag 25 och han 26 kanske, och då sa han att vi måste ha en stor rabatt här nu.
Och jag bara, vi kan inte fråga om det, vi är alldeles för nya.
Och då fick vi direkt 10%, och då kan man ju tänka sig om vi får 10% på våra största leverantörer från att vi inte har någon procents rabatt.
Vad det gör för bolagslönsamhet.
Man kan säga att 80% av våra inköpskostnader sjunker med 10%, så vi fick liksom 8% lägre kostnadsbas på våra faror över en natt, liksom bara för att han ställde frågan.
Ja, exakt.
Det är ju ofta de där svårt att kvantifiera sådana grejer som är väldigt, väldigt viktiga.
Men det är ju, en mening kan betyda extremt mycket.
Finns det några sådana här, vi hamnar nästan i fel ordning här, men finns det, det är ju ändå ett, både att ta in en delägare är ju ett stort beslut.
Du har ju, vad ska man säga, börja lära sig prut är ju ett stort beslut.
Finns det några fler sådana här, riktigt stora punkter i bolagets utveckling som, som kanske inte låter så stora men som, som verkligen har varit viktiga för att ni ska vara där ni är idag?
Alltså man tar learning, så om jag skulle stå och hålla någon sån här commencement speech, då skulle jag väl säga att, men än en gång går jag tillbaka till Jacqueline då, som var min första heltidsanställda kollega, som var med och byggde bolaget under mån.
Hennes pappa hade bakgrund i militären och hans delasansvar är inget ansvar.
Det hade han präntat in i henne och hon präntade in i mig och bolaget.
Det tycker jag är väldigt viktigt.
Så vad man gör så sitter vi och har ett möte, de här mötena jag berättade om då, och jag frågar såhär, tar du action?
Vem tar action?
Så vi inte bara säger, vi måste kolla på det här.
Det är liksom svindåligt, utan Joel kollar på det här, Victor kollar på det här.
När återkommer du bra, då kör vi en catch-up då.
Det jag tror det handlar om var väldigt, många som blir chefer pratar om att vara hård som chef.
Jag pratar om att vara tydlig.
Jag tycker det är en väldigt stor skillnad.
En hård chef, det låter inte bra, det är inte bra.
Men en tydlig chef, det uppskattar både mottagaren och du som själv, att du säger att du förväntar dig det här datumet.
Det tycker inte jag är att vara hård i och vara tydlig.
Jättebra distinktion.
Du har ju läst de här böckerna som ligger här i rummet, men då vet du säkert vad en level 5 leader är.
Ni andra får väl googla.
Men du vill ju ändå bygga ett riktigt stort bolag, en känsla i alla fall.
Vad är det du, är du själv en level 5 och vad är det du saknar för att inte vara det?
Nej, jag tror väldigt mycket som...
Är det du som kommer att driva detta när ni omsätter en miljard?
Det handlar inte om att jag inte tror, det är bara mer så här, jag som jag känner just nu, så kommer jag aldrig vilja sälja bolaget.
Det är för roligt och jag är för stolt över det och vi har så mycket kvar att göra så med det sagt så tror jag att jag kommer att göra bolaget när vi omsätter en miljard.
Men att jag är en bra ledare, men jag är väl halvbra tror jag.
Jag kan bara jämföra med mig själv, man ska aldrig jämföra med andra, men jag är oändligt mycket bättre än vad jag var för tio år sedan.
Men jag har fortfarande så sjukt mycket kvar att lära.
Och den dag jag tror att jag är bra, då ska jag sluta.
Jag känner att det är en bra punkt att avsluta intervjun här.
Jag är otroligt tacksam för att vi fick fråga ut dig.
Väldigt spännande intervju.
Tack snälla, jättekul att du kom.
Tack.
Jag brukar tänka att, för mig är det, kan jag köpa lunch ute?
Då känner jag mig lugn i huvudet.